are now enduring ongoing power outages
after days of severe cold weather
democrats are claiming it's the state's
stubborn reliance on fossil fuels
that's the problem but is it right
joining me now is texas lieutenant
governor dan patrick
dan there's been a lot of debate about
what's at the root of all of this
why is there so much confusion well
part of the confusion laura is that
first of all some data has been
has become fact when it's really a myth
we do not have 25 percent of
renewables on our best day in the summer
when the sun's out for 12 hours
maybe we can get up to 23 24 but like
right now we were planning during the
winter when the sun doesn't shine
and the wind does not blow as much about
12 percent on monday
well hold on lieutenant governor ted
cruz was on with hannity and he said
that you guys got 25 i'm pretty sure 25
percent of
your power from wind so that's not
that's just i'm sorry
ted's my friend i'm sorry that's just
incorrect uh wind and solar combined is
about
about 23 at your best day in other words
a few days a year
but during the winter time because the
sun's not out as much and the wind does
not blow as much
um we were counting on about 11 or 12
percent maybe 14 percent from when
during the
during this last week we were down to 2
because the turbines were frozen
and there's a lesson here the lesson is
we cannot go down this
road laura of green energy because right
now
we have almost everyone's power back we
had millions out several days ago we
have generation now power generation
for almost everyone and it's not wind
and it's not solar it's dark out and i
can't make the turbines go around
it's fossil fuel it's clean burning coal
it's nuclear
that's what this country and this state
need so we do
lead the country and win but it is not
25 percent of our everyday
power use so dan this is this has become
a political
you know lightning rod obviously it's
the worst thing to happen to texas and
since
you know one of the worst worst
hurricanes if not worse than that and
beta o'rourke is taking to the airwaves
to
make this a political issue not
surprisingly watch
texas you have an example of what
happens when a state is governed by
those who do not believe in government
state leadership that doesn't believe in
climate change wind and solar renewable
energy actually
over performed we've got to take action
as a state and on reducing our
dependence on fossil fuels
dan what does he get wrong other other
than everything
well he wants to take our guns and our
fossil fuel now apparently he has two
fistfuls of what he wants to take from
texas
so laura look we need a portfolio in
america we need a portfolio of texas
that's nuclear clean burning coal
that's fossil fuel uh this natural gas
you know we had this issue this week for
a couple of reasons one
an incredible freeze there was you're
talking about del rio where i know
you've been and i've been on the border
they had 10 inches of snow today
it's unheralded but what happened should
have never happened we have this
overseeing group a private company not
for profit called ercot
and they told us the leadership in the
state last week they were ready
for this so either the power generators
that power our our energy lied to them
or misled them or they misled us
because four days later this past monday
ercot now says
we were just a few megawatts away from
the whole system
going down we will have an investigation
beginning this week in the senate laura
and as president of the senate as
lieutenant governor a bill doesn't come
to the floor without
my signature on it there is not a bill
coming to the floor unless we
now mandate we made recommendations 10
years ago we thought they were doing
everything they said they were doing
obviously they have not so i'm angry
like people are angry
and they deserve to be angry this should
never have happened in texas maybe it's
time to get rid of her cut all together
and start with a new form
but we're going to get to the answers
we're going to find out what the hell
went wrong and we're going to fix it
and we're not no nonsense anymore we're
not going to let the lobbyists in five
thousand dollar suits come in and defend
various people well no please understand
this
what i understand is people were cold
and shivering and hungry
didn't have water and it should have
never happened we were not prepared
we were not told the truth and i'm not
accepting it and i don't think anyone in
the legislature is going to
accept it so we will move on and we will
fix it
we will be following this next week as
hearings begin uh
our prayers are with the people of texas
they're tough people but this was
this was hard to endure dan thank you
very much for joining us tonight